- [Tutor] We're told to consider
this matrix transformation
or this is a matrix that you can view,
represents a transformation
on the entire coordinate plane.
And then they tell us that the
transformation is performed
on the following rectangle.
So this is the rectangle
before the transformation
and they say, what is the area
of the image of the rectangle
under this transformation?
So the image of the rectangle
is what the rectangle becomes
after the transformation.
So pause this video and
see if you can answer that
before we work through it on our own.
All right, so the main
thing to realize is,
if we have a matrix transformation
or a transformation matrix like this
if we take the absolute
value of its determinant,
that value tells us how much
that transformation scales up
areas of figures.
So let's just do that,
let's evaluate the absolute
value of the determinant here.
So the absolute value of the determinant
would be the absolute value of 5 times 8,
5 times 8 minus 9 times 4, 9 times 4.
Remember for a 2 by 2 matrix,
the determinant is just this times this
minus this times that.
And so that's going to be the
absolute value of 40 minus 36
which is just the absolute value of 4
which is just going to be equal to 4.
So this tells us that this transformation
will scale up area by a factor of 4.
So what's the area before
the transformation?
Well, we can see that this is, let's see,
it's 5 units tall and it is 7 units wide.
So this has an area of 35 square
units, pre transformation.
So post transformation,
we just multiply it
by the absolute value of
the determinant to get,
let's see, 4 times 30 is 120
plus 4 times 5 is another 20.
So this is going to get us
to 140 square units and we're done.